republican senator lindsey graham has
become
one of the most pernicious republican
senators
part of why he is so slippery
is that lindsey graham knows how to
every once in a while
behave sort of normally despite being
mostly an incompetent and dangerous
buffoon who sucks up to trump at every
opportunity and so
as an example last week lindsey graham
gave a speech during the late at night
when the count of the electoral vote had
resumed after the armed insurrection was
quelled
at least temporarily lindsey graham gave
a very reasonable sounding speech saying
listen
i supported this president and i wanted
him to win
but this strategy isn't going to work
and that strategy isn't going to work
and in the end the reason we're here
is mostly perfunctory and we have no
choice but to say joe biden is the next
president and a lot of people said oh
okay not bad golf clap
uh he's m he's making some sense and
within just a couple of days of that
lindsey graham appears on fox news
begging for mercy for trump to avoid
being impeached or removed just pathetic
lindsey graham begging look at this
i'm calling on vice president-elect
biden to pick up the phone
and call nancy pelosi and the squad to
end the second impeachment
president trump gave a statement last
night that was helpful uh it hit the
mark
he wants to move on to a peaceful
transfer of power he wants this to end
calling on biden to call nancy pelosi
what in just those first 20 seconds
lindsay is talking about uh
he's making statements riddled with lies
and distortions
he wants biden to call pelosi
the house of representatives must
determine if trump's behavior is worthy
of impeachment
if it is the house must impeach it's
their responsibility
and it is their duty i don't want nor
need
joe biden calling nancy pelosi to
influence her one way or the other
if you said hey joe should call nancy to
encourage her to impeach no he shouldn't
no he shouldn't the decision on
impeachment is for the house of
representatives period
second you know lindsay says trump made
a helpful statement and committed to a
peaceful transfer
trump was essentially forced out there
to say the equivalent of now that i've
burned the whole house down
i promise not to light any more matches
and he did it under
under duress excuse me and he didn't
even mean it as
evidenced by the tweets that he sent
immediately after so 20 seconds
disgusting from lindsay let's look at
the end of what he had to say
president trump gave a statement last
night that was helpful
it hit the mark he wants to move on to a
peaceful
transfer of power he wants this to end
i've been with him most of the day he's
going to focus on his agenda
his successes for the american people in
the next few days but joe biden said
it's up to congress regarding
impeachment no president-elect biden
is up to you pick up the phone call
nancy pelosi chuck schumer and the squad
and tell them
stand down this will destroy the country
even further
you have the power to do that the
question is do you have the courage to
do
it joe biden was right it's up to
congress
lindsay is a disgusting trump tool and
also by the way
again with the meme of this will be
divisive and it will further
destroy the country i'm sick of the
hypocrisy
and this opportunist nonsense from from
these people
whenever they are the ones causing the
disunity they say
this is a time to come together we need
unity whenever they are out of power and
can't do any
anything as they will be in just a few
days they say well now we need
bipartisanship
whenever anger and wanting consequences
for actions turns against them because
of their radical behavior like last week
they caused us to get to this point and
now they say oh we need calm
and now that they've been as divisive as
anyone in history
in the united states they say oh
impeachment would be divisive now
impeachment's required the divisive acts
are the ones that warrant impeachment
when the facts say you must impeach you
must impeach and and by the way
had republican senators like lindsey
graham
voted to convict donald trump on
impeachment the first time
the riot never would have happened and
those
same republican senators now
think they get to tell us whether trump
should be impeached a second time
it's pathetic lindsay constantly playing
both
sides and and by the way the sick irony
of it failing
lindsay has been trying to play both
sides for years and he's been trying to
do it over the last uh
four days as well it failed lindsay
sort of gave a mildly reasonable speech
on the floor of the
the uh house during that joint session
on
on what was it wednesday night very
early thursday morning
but then he still is begging for mercy
for trump and defending trump
but he was at the airport at the end of
last week getting ready to get on a
plane
and he had to have police protection
because the mega trumpist people
were screaming traitor traitor traitor
and surrounding
lindsey graham so it's so pathetic that
even his mealy-mouthed uh hypocrisy
and playing both sides has not spared
him the ire from the same riotous
insurrectionists
who stormed the capitol last week and it
it all has to end there are such
bigger issues here that need to be dealt
with in this country to really get this
insanity under control
widespread ignorance as a virus the mind
virus of ignorance and lack of media
literacy is part of the problem
we will keep talking about the bigger
picture issues but what a pathetic
clown lindsey graham has really become
one of our sponsors today is magic spoon
the reason i'm such a fan of magic spoon
is they allow me to enjoy the delicious
breakfast cereals i loved as a kid
without all the sugar and without the
unhealthy ingredients because magic
spoon makes breakfast cereal
that you really can't tell apart from
those tasty sugary cereals that we all
know
but each serving of magic spoon has no
sugar
three net carbs and 11 grams of protein
so it's perfect for someone on a low
carb
keto diet just anybody trying to eat
healthier and cut back on the sugar
you can choose from cocoa frosted fruity
cinnamon blueberry or peanut butter they
all taste amazing
and magic spoon now lets you create your
own customized variety pack
with the flavors you choose they really
do stand by their product and will
refund 100 percent of your money
if you don't love it no questions asked
go to magicspoon.com
pacman to build your own custom variety
box today
make sure to use promo code pacman to
get free shipping
the link is right underneath this video